>> Greg: VIOLENCE URGING IN
CITIES, AND CRIMINALS ACTING
MORE BRAZEN THAN EVER,
NEW YORK CITY, BRUTALLY SUCKER
PUNCHED A 55-YEAR-OLD ASIAN
WOMAN THAT IS SICKENING.
NOW REPORTEDLY IN STABLE
CONDITIONS, THE SUSPECT CHARGED
WAS APPARENTLY ARRESTED EIGHT
TIMES IN THE PAST YEAR.
EIGHT TIMES.
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICER WAS
PUMMELED BY A HOMELESS MAN AND
TOLD BIND STANDERS STEPPED IN TO
HELP HER.
SO HAROLD, YOU LIVE IN NEW YORK,
I SEE YOU ALL THE TIME.
YOU SHOULD WEAR MORE CLOTHES
WHEN YOU TALK.
BUT THIS GUY WAS ARRESTED 17
TIMES, HE IS HOMELESS, EIGHT
TIMES IN THE PAST YEAR, YOU LIVE
HERE, WHAT DO YOU THINK, WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS A SPIKE IN CRIME,
BUT THESE CRIMES ARE VERY
SIMILAR, NOT EVEN LINKED TO
THEFT, JUST WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
THE REAL PROBLEM HERE?
>> Harlod: WE NEED TO STOP IT,
NOT TO DEFUND THE POLICE, PUT AS
MUCH AS WE CAN AND POLICE
DEPARTMENT, I THINK IT'S NAIVE
THAT YOU CAN'T HOLD A POLICE
ACCOUNTABLE AND NO FUND -- NOT
TO FUND THE POLICE.
ONE ASPECT OF THE DEFUND THE
POLICE CAN CONVERSATION THAT
GETS CAUGHT UP WHEN YOU THINK
BADLY ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY TALK
ABOUT DEFUNDING THE POLICE, WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH AND WHAT POLICE DO
WHETHER WE ARE THE FORCE WITHIN
THE FORCE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
ALSO CONCERNS AROUND BELL
REFORM, I THINK IT WAS
WELL-INTENTIONED, BUT I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT WE ARE GETTING
AFTER WERE SOLVING THE PROBLEM
THAT WE WANT TO SOLVE, WE MAY BE
HAVE OVERREACHED HERE, MAYBE WE
SHOULD TRY TO GET IT RIGHT, WHAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS NOT
WORKING.
KIDS, MOMS AND DADS, EVERYBODY
SHOULD FEEL SAFE WALKING OUTSIDE
THE DOOR.
>> Greg: DAGEN, IT IS A CREEPY
ATMOSPHERE.
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT SEEK ARE
NOT WELL.
AND MY THEORY IS THAT TODAY ARE,
WHEN THEY LOOK AT SHELTERS THERE
IS NOT A PLACE FOR THEM.
THEY ARE BEING SPUN OUT OF
PRISON.
THEY DON'T CARE BECAUSE THEY GO
BACK TO JAIL AND MAYBE JAIL IS
PREFERABLE TO THE SHELTERS.
WE GIVE $800 MILLION TO
BILL de BLASIO'S WIFE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
THAT SHOULD HAVE SOLVED MORE
THAN THIS, AND NOTHING HAS
HAPPENED.
>> Dagen: NO, THAT WAS A
BOONDOGGLE, YOU COULD'VE THROWN
THAT MONEY DOWN AN OPEN MANHOLE
IN NEW YORK CITY.
THE PROBLEM IS, AND I DON'T MEAN
TO DISPARAGE POLICE, BUT WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE MENTALLY ILL, I
SEE PEOPLE, I'M NOT GOING TO BE
SOMEONE RUBBING HUMAN ON THE
OUTSIDE OF CVS IS NOT GOING TO
ARREST THAT INDIVIDUAL.
WITH THIS MAN WHO ASSAULTED THIS
ASIAN WOMAN, HE HAS BEEN
ARRESTED 40 TIMES.
SO ON BAIL REFORM EVERY TIME YOU
GET PICKED UP, YOU ARE RIGHT
BACK OUT ON THE STREET AND THEN
THE CRIME IS NOT PROSECUTED.
IF THEY PICK UP SOMEONE MENTALLY
ILL, THAT INDIVIDUAL MIGHT GO TO
BELLEVUE HOSPITAL FOR 72 HOURS.
THERE IS A VAST DANCE DELAYED --
DANCE TOULOUSE STATION OF THE
MENTALLY ILL SINCE JFK AND IT
HAS ONLY GOTTEN WORSE, WHICH
MEANS THAT THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
HELP FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED IT.
BUT PEOPLE WHO WATCH THE MAYORAL
PRIMARY, ERIC ADAMS, FORMER
POLICE CAPTAIN STRONG ON POLICE.
BUT KAREN GARCIA WHO HAS BEEN
BACKED BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SAID OFFICERS WHO DID NOT WEAR
MASKS DURING LAST YEAR'S PROTEST
HAVE TO BE DOCKED TO THEIR PAY.
THAT IS HER STANCE.
>> Greg: THIS IS NEW YORK, BUT
WE ARE SEEING THINGS AROUND THE
COUNTRY, BUT NOT IN THE SUBURBS,
IS THIS SOMETHING ONLY THE CITY
PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH IS IT
COVID RELATED?
>> Jesse: IT IS, SO THANKS FOR
BRINGING US BACK TO THE CITY,
GREG.
THERE IS A JUDGE OUT THERE WHO
IS STARING IN THE EYEBALLS OF
THIS DERANGED LUNATIC, LOOKED AT
THE RAP SHEET AND SLAMMED THE
GAVEL DOWN AND SAID PROBATION
AND DID NOT SENTENCE THE GUY,
THERE IS A BAD JUDGE THAT
COULD'VE THROWN THE BOOK AT THIS
GUY AND DID IT, AND BACK IN THE
DAY I WOULD HAVE BEEN AT THE
JUDGE'S DOORSTEP AT 6:00 A.M.
AND STUCK THE MIC IN HIS FACE
BECAUSE HE IS A BILLION --
VILLAIN AND HAVE TO HUMILIATE IN
ORDER TO GET TOUGHER, BECAUSE
WITHOUT A JUDGE THAT GETS TOUGH,
YOU WILL KEEP ROLLING OUT THE
PURPOSE AND THEY WILL KEEP
PERMITTING -- COMMITTING CRIMES.
THE INSTANT ZEUS -- INSTANT TO
THEY ARE READY TO HAVE ALL OF
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM, BUT YOU
CAN HAVE SOME LUNATIC OUT THERE
AND STALK SOMEONE PUSH THEM IN
FRONT OF THE TRAIN AND THEN THE
NEXT DAY THEY ARE OUT ON THE
STREETS AGAIN, WE NEED TO
DEINSTITUTIONALIZATE THESE
PEOPLE, BECAUSE THEY ARE SICK.
>> Sandra: YOU LOOK AT THE
DEFUNDING THE POLICE MOVEMENT
AND A LOOK AT THE SPIKE IN RISE
IN CRIME AND YOU SEE VIDEO LIKE
THIS THAT MAKES YOUR HEART HURT,
THANK GOD WE ARE SEEING THAT SHE
IS IN STABLE CONDITION, BUT HOW
DO YOU EXPECT TO RETURN FULL
WORKFORCE TO A CITY IN NEW YORK
WHEN YOU SEE THESE RANDOM AWFUL
ATTACKS THAT ARE HAPPENING ON
CITIES --
FOR ANYBODY WALKING DOWN A BLOCK
IN NEW YORK RIGHT NOW, I DON'T
FEEL SAFE.
THIS COULD HAPPEN ANYONE
ANYWHERE AT ANY MOMENT.
>> Greg: THE THING THAT IS SO
SHOCKING ABOUT THIS MODERN TYPE
OF VIOLENCE IS THAT IT IS THE
VICTIMS.
WHO HITS AN OLD LADY?
IN THE BACK OF YOUR HEAD THAT
IS --
>> Jesse: PREDATORS GO FOR THE
WEAKEST.
THAT IS WHO THEY ARE TARGETING.
>> Greg: THEY ARE NOT EVEN
TAKING THINGS, THEY ARE JUST
POUNDING THEM, SO OBVIOUSLY
PSYCHOTIC AND A SPECIAL K.
>> Jesse: THAT